in my recent poll with over 75 000
responses css topped the list as the
most painful technology web developers
have to work with they say it's broken
chaotic and too damn hard there's even a
conspiracy that it's bad by design to
protect the app stores but i think css
is awesome
it's definitely bloated and difficult to
learn comprehensively but that's only
because it's had to evolve over the last
25 years
it came out at a time when netscape was
the top browser and the idea of a
responsive layout was more than a decade
away
as more browsers hit the market they all
implemented css in different ways
leading to code that works in one
browser but not the other requiring you
the developer to write a bunch of
confusing vendor prefixes in your code
just to make it work across all browsers
so i totally get why you would hate css
but today is a therapy session where
you'll learn how to write clean css
using modern features
while avoiding the bad code that you
shouldn't have to write in 2021
if you're new here like and subscribe
and leave your favorite css pro tip in
the comments
i'll pick a few of them to win this
one-of-a-kind t-shirt next week the
first thing you need to know
is how to learn css the way not to learn
css is to use a framework like bootstrap
or
tailwind they're sexy tools that can
help you get a nice looking ui quickly
but if you use something like tailwind
in your project
it's like getting married for one you
won't learn css fundamentals you'll
learn tailwind
and two if you ever change your mind
you'll have to go through a very nasty
divorce you want a divorce
i have wings tally i want to fly
when you learn basic css you'll have
more control over your code
creativity and freedom the best piece of
advice that i didn't receive until well
into my web development career was to
learn the css
box model because when you understand it
everything else in the language starts
to make more sense
in fact it's so easy i'll just teach you
the box model right now
think of every html element as a box
inside that box you have the content
which can have a width and height you
can add padding around that box to
squeeze the content then you can add a
border around the outside
then additional invisible space around
the border called a margin
everything in css related to layout and
position is influenced by the box model
if you open up chrome dev tools you can
see how the box model is computed for
any element on the page
and that brings me to tip number two
don't use chrome when debugging css
instead check out firefox their dev
tools are generally superior especially
when it comes to css if i inspect an
element i have a breakdown of the box
model like i do in chrome but i can also
edit properties on it directly
and firefox gives me a breakdown of all
the properties that are influencing the
box model
it also provides useful annotations in
the html like when one element is
causing another element to overflow
and firefox also provides really nice
graphics for flex and grid layout
speaking of which layout or the
positioning of elements relative to each
other
has historically been one of the most
challenging aspects of css
like the age-old question of how do i
center a div both horizontally and
vertically
one option is to give the child absolute
positioning then move it to the bottom
right corner by using the top and left
properties
then translate it back 50 to put it in
the center
that can work but it's incredibly
unintuitive a much better approach with
modern css
is flexbox which allows you to create a
flexible column or row
anywhere in the ui when an element has
display flex it also has an x and y axis
on which you can align its children the
children flow one way which is known as
the main axis
and can be aligned in the center with
the justify content property
perpendicular to that is the cross axis
and we can move our element to the
center with the align items property
flexbox is usually the first tool i
reach for when it comes to layout
but it does have one major drawback if
you have a big complex ui with many
intersecting rows and columns you may
end up with a lot of container or
wrapper elements in your html
these elements have no semantic meaning
and are just there so your css code has
something to attach itself to
luckily there's a modern css feature
called a grid that can obliterate much
of your code
unlike flexbox which only deals with
individual columns and rows and grid
allows you to think about the big
picture layout if you've been a web
developer for a long time
it may look familiar because it's very
similar to table layout way back in the
day
it's just much more developer friendly
when you set an element to display grid
you can then define its children as a
bunch of columns and rows
columns have a width which can be
defined with the grid template columns
property we have three values here
separated by spaces
which means our grid has three columns
notice the fr value
or fractional unit which will
responsibly share the available space
with other columns in the grid we can
also define some rows
and now every element inside the grid
will be positioned automatically
but the important thing to notice is the
amount of html and css that we've
eliminated compared to flexbox layout or
god forbid table layout
now ninety percent of the time when we
talk about responsive layouts we're just
talking about changing the width of
something
based on the available space on the
device or viewport there are many ways
you might do that
for example you might have an article
that has a preferred width of 50
but on small screens you want to make it
fixed at 200 pixels or fixed at 800
pixels on large screens
you could do that by writing media
queries that will apply css
conditionally based on the viewport size
the only problem with this is that media
queries will make you want to off
yourself as the project grows larger the
good news though
is that you can turn the tables by using
functions like min max and clamp
we could refactor this code to set the
width to a clamped value
that has a minimum of 200 pixels a max
of 600
and then a preferred value of 50 turning
13 lines of code into one for a 92
code reduction speaking of code
reduction here's a little bonus tip in
css we often end up with these very long
hard to read class names but did you
know that you can use emoji characters
as class names
instead of flexible container why not
just use a flex emoji
or instead of red text why not red
lipstick is that a good idea
i don't know give it a try at your job
and let me know what your boss says
about it
we have sort of a problem here yeah now
this next tip is really going to blow
your mind if you've ever had to code a
responsive image or video
that maintains a certain aspect ratio i
had to do this recently on fireship io
to embed videos with a 16x9 aspect ratio
which requires this hack where you put
56.25
padding on the top then give the child
absolute positioning today
although it's not supported everywhere
yet we can use the aspect ratio property
instead of that padding nonsense we can
just define the aspect ratio on the
video
and we're done eliminating css code is a
big part of making it more enjoyable
but of equal importance is making your
code more flexible so that refactoring
is not a total
nightmare a great way to achieve that is
with css custom properties or variables
notice how we're using the same color
value in multiple places if we decide to
change the color we need to modify
every line of code that references it a
better approach is to define a global
variable on the root selector which can
then be referenced wherever it's needed
and now when you decide to change it you
only have to modify one line of code
variables cascade like everything else
in css which means you can override them
by redefining them somewhere deeper in
the tree you can also combine
them to compose more complex values for
example we might define our rgb color
based on the value of three other
variables and this flexibility will
really change your life
by allowing you to quickly swap out
different themes for your website
now css is not really a programming
language in the traditional sense
but it does have the ability to run
basic calculations using the calc
function
it allows you to calculate a value with
some basic math but the really cool
thing about it is that you can combine
different units
like you might want to subtract 50
pixels from the current viewport width
in our code here we have an animation
where elements drop in from the top but
we want to stagger them so they come in
one after the other
one way to achieve that is by applying a
different animation delay for every
single element but that's very
repetitive
and hard to refactor a more
sophisticated approach is to define an
inline css variable for every item that
defines its order
then we can define the animation delay
as a calculation
of the order variable times 100
milliseconds
and now we can handle an infinite number
of elements without increasing our css
footprint thanks to the combined powers
of calc
and variables now i know i just said css
is not a programming language but did
you know that it actually has a state
management mechanism built
into it you can keep track of a running
count in your css code without ever
writing a line of javascript
if you want to number headings in your
html the naive way to do it is to
manually add those numbers in the html
itself
because if you ever want to splice in a
new heading you'll have to renumber
everything manually
a smarter approach might be a css
counter you can create a counter in your
code
using the counter reset property give it
a name of anything you want
then increment it whenever the desired
selector is applied it'll start from 0
then add 1 to every h1 element in the
dom
and now you never have to worry about
numbering things in your html
and that brings us to our final tip when
building a complex drop-down menu you
might assume that some javascript is
involved to manage the open and closed
state of the menu
but you might be surprised at how far
you can get with just plain css
now you're most likely familiar with the
focus pseudo class which is applied to
an element when you go into a form input
or click on a button
the problem is that when building a drop
down you might use focus to open a menu
but then when you click on something
inside that menu it loses focus and
closes
and that's when you reach for javascript
to manage state however there's another
pseudo class called focus within and it
stays active
if any children also have focus and that
one simple feature
can eliminate a lot of javascript used
to toggle on and off states and with
that you have 10 ways to make your css
code more enjoyable to work with
but remember those browser vendor
prefixes i mentioned earlier in the
video
well that stuff's like herpes it's not
going away luckily we do have effective
medications that will make it barely
noticeable
a tool you should know about is post css
which itself uses a tool called auto
prefixer
to add all the vendor prefixes
automatically in addition it allows you
to use modern css features even if
they're not supported on your targeted
browsers
in addition you may look into
pre-processors like sas less or stylus
but we'll save those for a future video
make sure to be a subscriber and leave a
comment below because next week i'll
announce the winners of the t-shirt
giveaway thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one